قالت الاذاعه الاسرائيليه ان واشنطن
استدعت سفيره اسرائيل لديها واعربت له عن
قلقها من اقرار الكنيست قانونا يلغي اخلاء
مستوطنات بالضفه الغربيه ووصفت واشنطن
القرار بان من شانه رفع توتر خلال شهر
رمضان واعياد الفصح اليهودي والمسيحي من
جهه وصف رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه قرارا
بانه تصحيح لقانون تمييزي حضر على اليهود
العيش في بيوتهم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي حيثيات الموقف
الامريكي من قرار الكنيست وكيف نقرا في
سياق الرسائل الاخيره الصادره عن واشنطن
ازاء الحكومه الاسرائيليه اليمينيه التي
يقودها نتنياهو الى اي حد يعكس موقفه
واشنطن رغبه حقيقيه في كبح جماح حكومه
اليمين المتطرف في اسرائيل وكيف استقبل
التل ابيب المواقف الامريكيه وما خياراتها
للتعامل معها وكيف ينظر الفلسطينيون الى
دوري واشنطن واسلوبها في التعاطي مع
الحكومه الاسرائيليه وما مدى قناعتهم بان
الاجراءات الامريكيه كافيه لردع تل ابيب
ونزع فتيل التوتر بالمنطقه
[موسيقى]
اذا في اطار ردود الفعل او رد الفعل
الامريكي على اقرار الكنيسه الاسرائيلي
قانونا ينهي بشكل فوري قرارا كان نافذا
منذ عام 2005 باخلاء اربع مستوطنات في
شمالي الضفه الغربيه استدعت الخارجيه
الامريكيه بحسب الاذاعه الاسرائيليه سفيره
تل ابيب لدى واشنطن
السفير الذي مثل امام نائبتي وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي والديشيرمان ابلغ بقلق
واشنطن من قرار الكنيست ووصفها القرار
بانه استفزازي وتحذيرها على لسانه مسؤوله
الامريكي على لسان المسؤوله الامريكيه من
امكانيه ان تدفع الخطوه الاسرائيليه الى
مزيد من التوتر خلال شهر رمضان واعياد
الفصح اليهودي والمسيحي
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا في الجزء الاول
من هذه الحلقه من واشنطن جول روبل مساعد
نائب وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه السابق ومن
تل ابيب معنا جولان برهوم المحلل السياسي
الاسرائيلي سنبدا معك سيده جول روبن لماذا
اختارت الخارجيه الامريكيه هذه الخطوه غير
الاعتياديه في التعامل مع السلطات
الاسرائيليه المتمثله باستدعاء السفير
للاعراب عن قلقها على ما وصفته بالخطوه
الاستفزازيه المتمثله بالتراجع عن قانون
الفصل الاحدي
نعم يسعدنا ان نكون معكم اولا هذا القرار
من قبل وزاره الخارجيه باستدعاء السفير
الاسرائيلي هو خطوه مهمه لها مغزاها من
قبل اداره بايدن وتم الاقدام عليها بسبب
قرارك نسيت الاسرائيلي لتغيير القانون وهو
سحب القوات
الاسرائيليه من الضفه الغربيه وغازه هذا
اثار التوترا في واشنطن لان هذا سيفتح
الباب امام عوده
المستوطنات للجزء الشمالي من الضفه
الغربيه وهذا قد يثير حاله من العنف اداره
بايدن تعمل جاهده مع الاردن ومع مع مصر
قمتين عقدتا في شرم الشيخ والعقبه
بمحاوله لضمان ان تكون الاوضاع هادئه في
عيد الفصح اليهودي ورمضان هذا الخطوه لن
على ذلك ابدا لهذا السبب راينا وزاره
الخارجيه تقول ان اسرائيل اقدمت على خطوه
من شانها ان تؤدي الى العنف والسيد
يتنياهو قام بذلك قبل يوم من قمه شرم
الشيخ التي وعدت فيها الحكومه الاسرائيليه
بعدم الاتخاذ ايه خطوات استفزازيه لهذا
سبب نرى هذه
الخطوات العلنيه واستدعاء السفير ولكن في
فيما يتعلق بخطوه الاستدعاء يعني كما ذكرت
استدعاء السفير السفير الاسرائيلي في
واشنطن من جانب الخارجيه الامريكيه هي
خطوه غير اعتياديه ما الرساله من وراء هذا
الامر
نعم انتم الحقون في ذلك هي غير معهوده
وغير معتاده هذا يحدث عاده في وزاره
الخارجيه عندما تكون هناك مشكله مباشره
تجعل الحكومه الامريكيه تريد التواصل مع
حكومه اخرى على اعلى المستويات وان يكون
التواصل ليس من خلال المؤتمرات الصحفيه
والناطق باسم الخارجيه بل من خلال الحكومه
الوزاره مباشره وهذه المره كانت
هي التي تحدثت مع السفير طبعا بعد اجتماع
عقد في الخارجيه
وخساره هناك قرار بان هذا الامر يجب ان لا
ينظر اليه كاجراء استفزازي فحسبن اسرائيل
بل ستكون له تداعيات واذا ما اسرائيل
استمرت في ذلك ستكون له تداعيه انا في
رايي الحكومه الاسرائيليه قد لا تجعل
مستعمرات هناك لكن المواطنين الاسرائيلين
قد يحاولون القيام سيد جولان برهوم من تل
ابيب كيف باعتقادك ستتلقى الحكومه
الاسرائيليه هذه الخطوه الامريكيه
بدايه مرحبا وتحياتي لك وللجميع واشكر لكم
على هذا الاستضافه الكريمه اريد اولا ان
اقول ان في طبيعه الحال هناك علاقات طبيعه
وطيده قويه بين الولايات المتحده من
الحزبين على فكره ودوله اسرائيل ولكن
استدعاء الرئيس هذه غير المره الاولى الذي
اتى الامر يحصل في طبيعه الحال اسف هناك
خلافات هناك عدم موافقه على فكره غير من
اليوم من سنه 1967 كانت ايام الولايات
المتحده كانت دائما مؤلمه مؤمنه اسف بقيام
دوله فلسطينيه مستقله على اساس حدود
67 تقسيم كامل بالنسبه لمدينه مدينه القدس
وما عدا الاداره الامريكيه السابقه ومن
الوقت انا سالتك
لكيف يمكن للحكومه الاسرائيليه ان تتعامل
مع هذه الخطوه كما ذكرنا ليس معتادا من
الخارجيه الامريكيه ان تستدعي السفير
الاسرائيلي في واشنطن
اريد ان اكمل وهذا يكون في اعتقادي احلى
واحسن شرف اولا عدم موافقه كانت دائما
قائمه وموجوده في اعتقادي نعم حان الوقت
انا مؤمن بشفافيه انا غير مؤمن
بالعباسيه انا مؤمن ان الامور تكون واضحه
وهذه المصلحه مشتركه للجميع نعم انتخبت
حكومه معينه هناك خلافه اسرائيل لكن
الخلاف بين اليمين الاسرائيلي اليوم دوله
اسرائيل كما تعرفين موجوده للاسف الشديد
في ازمه ولكن الازمه لا تخص لموضوع
المناطق يهودا وسامره الضفه غربيه على هذا
موضوع هناك اجماع داخل اسرائيل عندما هناك
اجماع موافقه عامه داخل اسرائيل
في نفس الوقت هناك مكان للتغيير مواقف
معينه عند التي موجوده عند خصوصا عند
الحزب الديمقراطي ولكن انا مؤمن بمحاولات
ولكن المصالح المشتركه اذا يسمح لي
بالاختصار المصالح المشتركه فهي اهم من
ذلك اقوى من ذلك بكل ما يخص للعدو المشترك
ودوله اسرائيل ابقى معنا سيد تعقيبا على
استدعاء الخارجيه الامريكيه السفيره
الاسرائيلي في واشنطن للاحتجاج على قرار
الكنيست الذي يمهد لعوده المستوطنين الى
اربع مستوطنات شماليه الضفه قال رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي نتنياهو الى حكومته لا
تنوي اقامه مستوطنات جديده رغم قرار
الكنيست لكن نتنياهو عاد ليصف خطوه
الكنيست بانها تصحيح لما وصفه بانه قانون
تمييزي حضر على اليهود العيش في بيوتهم
بحسب تعبيره
نقل عن مسؤولين امريكيين قولهم ان استدعاء
السفير الاسرائيلي كان نتيجه تصريحات وزير
الماليه ومساله الاصلاح القضائي اضاف
الموقع ان هؤلاء المسؤولين اكدوا له وانا
اداره بايدن كانت تفضل عدم المواجهه مع تل
ابيب من اجل التنسيق ضد الطائرات وتعزيز
اتفاقيه التطبيع لكنها كانت تتوقع حدوث
ازمه مع الحكومه الاسرائيليه في وقت ما
وانها حاولت تاجيل تلك المواجهه قدر
الامكان بحسب ما نقله الموقع اعود اليك في
واشنطن اذا نتنياهو ردا على ما يبدو
رفضا دوليا للخطوه التي جرى القيام بها
بالعوده عن قانون الفصل الاحادي اوضح في
تصريح انه لن يجري بناء مستوطنات جديده هل
من شان ذلك ان
يضع حدا للقلق في واشنطن
كلا لن يكون ذلك كافيا اولا رئيس لوزاره
كما كنت اقول من قبل هو قد لا يتخذ قرارا
رسميا بنفسه في بناء مستوطنات لكن هذا لا
يعني ان المواطنين الاسرائيلين لن يحاولوا
عمل ذلك وربما
سيحاولون وضع منازل متنقله او ما يشبه ذلك
كما فعلوا ذلك لخلق وقائع وحقائق على
الارض السؤال هل ستقوم حكومه نتنياهو بطرد
هؤلاء وسحب هذه المنازل انا لا اعتقد ذلك
لهذا السبب هنا اشكاليه مهمه ايضا ان
قانون
2005 الذي سمى قانون فك الارتباط من غزه
اريال شارون احد اكثر القاده التحفظا
ويمينيا في اسرائيل سحب القوات
الاسرائيليه
غير صحيح ربما
انظر بنيامين نتناول يتعرض لمطالب امريكيه
وهو يريد ان يقود على هذه السفينه عندما
هو يتعرض لمطالب اوروبيه وامريكيه وشرق
اوسطيه ولكن مبدئيا نعم البناء في مناطق
يهود والسامره مستمر
واعتقادح الموقف شكرا
للشعوب العربيه السياسيه الاسرائيلي
والمحاضر في مركز الدبلوماسيه العامه من
تل ابيب وينضم الينا الان في بقيه هذه
الحلقه
السيد سعيد عريقات الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
من واشنطن مرحبا بك سيد سعيد دعنا نتوقف
بدايه عند تقييمك للخطوه الامريكيه
المتمثله باستدعاء السفير الاسرائيلي
للتعبير عن الاحتجاج والقلق والخوف من هذه
الخطوه بالتراجع عن قانون الفصل الاحادي
واعتباره خطوه استفزازيه كيف قيمت هذه
الخطوه
اولا كل عام والامه العربيه والاسلاميه
بالف خير بمناسبه حلول شهر رمضان المبارك
عاده وعلينا جميعا باليمن والبركه
بالنسبه
لاستدعاء السفير الاسرائيلي
يوم امس من قبل وزاره الخارجيه والاقامه
نعم هي حقيقه حدث استثنائي اخر سفير
استدعيت الى الوزاره كان الاسبوع الماضي
عندما استدعيه
السفير الروسي على سبيل المثال من التعبير
عن استياء الحكومه الامريكيه ولكن حقيقه
شتان بين الموقف الامريكي من روسيا
والموقف الامريكي من اسرائيل علينا ان
نبالغ بمدى اثر ذلك على العلاقات المميزه
يعني لا زالت الحكومه الامريكيه انا كنت
بالخارجيه يوم امس ودار النقاش حول هذا
الموضوع ودائما الاداره تصر على ان
العلاقه مع اسرائيل
مقدسه والامن والامن الاسرائيلي المقدس
وبالتالي نعم هناك كلمات قويه خرجت يوم
امس وانا سالت كيف للولايات المتحده ان
تضع وزنا وراء هذه الكلمات لكن حقيقه ليس
في جعبه الولايات المتحده ما ستفعله نعم
هناك الكثير قد تفعله ويمكن لها ان تفعله
ولكنها لا ترغب بفعل ذلك وبالتالي يجب ان
نضعه في السياق الولايات المتحده هي غير
راضيه عن الحكومه الحاليه غير راضيه عن
التصرفات هي تاخذ بعين الاعتبار المظاهرات
العارمه التي تقوم كل اسبوع ربما كل يوم
في تل ابيب كذلك هناك حاله عدم رضاء كبيره
جدا بين
المواطنه اليهودي الامريكي المواطنين
اليهود الامريكيين الذين يشكلون قاعده
قويه للحزب الديمقراطي ولرئيس جو بايدن
بشكل كبير فاذا كل هذه الامور تدفعه
بالولايات المتحده لاتخاذ على الاقل في
تصريحاتها وبياناتها كلمات قويه لتظهر عدم
لتظهر استيائها وعدم
رغبتها في رؤيه المزيد من هذه الخطوات
ولكن عمليا في تقديري لن نرى خطوات على
الارض وكما ذكر
المحلل من من تل ابيب الاستيطان مستمر لم
يتوقف ولو للحظه يعني نعم كان هناك
الرساله التي وجهها ايه شارون الى الرئيس
عندئذ جوردن مثل هذا التعهد ولكن حقيقه
الاستيطان استمر وترعرع وكبر الان هناك
حوالي 700 الف مستوطن في الضفه الغربيه
فاذا نعم الكلام طويل ولكن الفعل في في
الموضوع الذي ذكرته السيد جول روبن سيد
جول
الفلسطينيين يقولون ان هناك كلام ربما
مختلف من جانب هذه الاداره الامريكيه ولكن
على صعيد الافعال لا يوجد شيء حتى فيما
تعاهدت هذه الاداره الامريكيه بفعله لصالح
الفلسطينيين لم تقم بشيء منه على الارض ما
السبب
سؤال ملائم وجيه الفلسطينيين يعانون تحت
الاحتلال وما تقوم به اداره بايدن في
مؤخرا هي تحاول ان تظهر ان الحاله الامنيه
في الضفه الغربيه وايضا الفلسطيني يعانون
من قبل هجمات اسرائيليه احيانا ضدها
اهداف شرعيه مشروعه في اوقات اخرى شملت
المدنيين لهذا السبب الدعم للسلطه
الفلسطينيه والدعم الاقتصادي لها نامل ان
يساعد ذلك اوضاع الفلسطيني لكن
اداره بايدن تحاول ان تطقي على صبرها دون
ان ينفذ ليس فقط في اجتماع شرم الشيخ لكن
الرئيس بايدند تهاتف مع نتنياه
وكل هذه المظاهرات ضد نتنياهو يبدو بانها
موجهه ضده بسبب الموقف من الجهاز القضائي
والمحكمه هذا يؤثر في موقفه الان يبدو ان
هناك ضغطا يزداد نوعا ما ضدنا نتنياهو
وايضا
اليهود الامريكيين عندما جاءت مصر الى
الولايات المتحده كان هناك
اعتراض على وجوده بسبب تصريحاته التي تنم
عن كراهيه هناك دينميه جديده لم نراها منذ
سنوات سيد سعيد يعني في نفس الاطار اللي
يتحدث به جول روبن يعني اليمين المتطرف في
هذه الحكومه الاسرائيليه ياخذها من ازمه
الى اخرى على الصعيد الدولي
اخرها موضوع التراجع عن قانون الفصل
الاحاديثي قبلها
تصريحات تصريحات بين جزير الازمه
الدبلوماسيه الان مع الاردن كل ذلك
باعتقادك كيف من شانه ان ينعكس على القضيه
ككل
اولا لناخذ بعين الاعتبار انه نعم هناك
شرخ ما بين اليمين وبين
الليبراليين الديمقراطيين الاسرائيليين
على الكثير من المسائل مساله يعني كيف
تحكم البلد ومن يقودها وما هي القوانين
خاصه بالنسبه لبعض
الامور التي يهتمون بها هذا القطاع
الليبرالي مثل القضاء مثل حقوق المثليين
والى اخره لكن ليس هناك
خلافا وانا اشدد على هذه النقطه ليس هناك
خلافا على ما يبدو بين القوه اليمينيه
التي تحكم والتي تصرح هذه التصريعات
العنصريه وبين القوى الليبراليه التي
تتظاهر التي لم تبرز ولو مره واحده
مثلا اشارات او يافتات تتحدث عن الاحتلال
او انه انا لهذا الاحتلال ان ينتهي فاذا
اليمين يشعر انه يمثل الرغبه الاسرائيليه
العامه نعم هناك خلافات ايديولوجيه في
مساله الحكم ولكن يبدو انه ليس هناك خلافا
على مساله استمرار
الاحتلال مساله العنف الذي يمارس ضد الشعب
الفلسطيني وكذلك ليس هناك جديه في الموقف
الامريكي يعني حقيقه
من المذهل على سبيل المثال رمضان استدعاء
السفير الاسرائيلي سيد سعيد هل يمكن
فلسطينيا البناء على هذه الخطوه
فلسطينيا لا الفلسطينيون في موقع صعب لا
يستطيعون البناء على شيء
الولايات المتحده تفرض عليهم شروط
لن تقترب من فضلها على اسرائيل باي شكل من
الاشكال هي تجبرهم على الذهاب الى شرم
الشيخ تتحدث عن التنسيق الامني تتحدث عن
ضروره الكف عن اتخاذ الخطوات الاحاديه
ونحن لا نرى الا خطوات نحاديه من قبل
اسرائيل فقط اريد اريد ان اشير الى انه
حتى في تقرير حقوق الانسان الذي صدر قبل
يومين الولايات المتحده تمر عابرا عن كثير
من الامور التي تمارس اسرائيل ضد
الفلسطينيين لم تذكر الصحفيه الامريكيه
الفلسطينيه شيرين ابو عاقله الا عابرا في
هذا التقرير فاذا نعم هناك نوع من التغاضي
من قبل الولايات المتحده التوقع بان يقوم
تقوم السلطه ويقوم الفلسطينيون بممارسه
اشياء لن تطلبها من اسرائيل شكرا جزيلا لك
سعيد على الكاتب والمحلل السياسي من
واشنطن وشكرا
نائب مساعد نائب وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
السابق ايضا ضيفنا من واشنطن
الى هنا مشاهدينا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر شكرا لمتابعتكم والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]